i opened my second podcast conversation
with elon musk
with a
question about consciousness and
panzykism the question was
quote does consciousness permeate all
matter i don't know why i opened the
conversation this way he looked at me
like what the hell is this guy talking
about
so he said no because we wouldn't be
able to tell if it did or not so it's
outside the realm of the scientific
method
do you agree or disagree with elon
musk's answer
i disagree i guess i i guess i do think
consciousness pervades matter in fact i
think consciousness is the ultimate
nature
of matter
um
so
as for whether it's outside
of the scientific method
i think there's
a fundamental challenge at the heart of
the science of consciousness that we
need to face up to which is that
consciousness is is not publicly
observable
all right i can't look inside your head
and see your feelings and experiences
we know about consciousness not you know
not from doing experiments or public
observation
we just know about it from our immediate
awareness of our feelings and
experiences
so it's qualitative not quantitative as
you talk about yeah that's another
aspect of it so there are a couple of
reasons consciousness
i think is not susceptible to the
standard or not fully susceptible to the
standard scientific approach one reason
you've just raised is that it's
qualitative rather than quantitative
another reason is it's not publicly
observable so i mean science science is
used to dealing with
uh unobservables right you know
fundamental particles quantum wave
functions other universes none of these
things are
observable
but there's an important difference
with all these things
we postulate unobservables
in order to explain what we can observe
right in the whole of science
that's that's the that's how it works in
the case of consciousness
in the unique case of consciousness the
thing we are trying to explain
is not publicly observable and that is
utterly unique
if we want to fully bring science into
consciousness we need a more expansive
conception of the scientific method so
it doesn't mean we can't explain
consciousness scientifically
but we need to rethink what science is
you